in this video I'm going to talk about
the nearest Targaryen fate in final
season I'm going to explain you how
Danny's role will look like in the last
six episodes of Game of Thrones as well
as if Danny will ever sit on the Iron
Throne and rule over the Seven Kingdoms
Daenerys accompanied with Jon Snow is
heading to the north with all her
remaining dragons and armies not to
conquer it but rather to save it from
the night King and his army of the Dead
Daenerys and John are sailing towards
white Harbor the main seaport of the
north with the unsullied once they
arrive over there there who me to the
track in the Kings Road and then ride
together to Winterfell according to
reliable sources there will be a big
meeting between Daenerys and Sansa Stark
once Danny finally reaches Winterfell
having in mind that Sansa back in the
second episode of the seventh season
stated at the nearest doesn't want to
help the north but rather wants to
conquer it many fans are likely to
assume that the stark sisters including
the other nodes and Lords will not
accept any as good as Jon did not
mention is their queen but they might be
wrong as near said herself in the season
7 finale she is not heading north to
conquer the north but to save it and
that something the northern Lords will
see for themselves in the very beginning
of the final season sensible see for
herself who the natural is and what her
true intentions are and without a doubt
accept her as the North's most trusted
Ally and it's only hope censor however
might stay to both John and Daenerys
that risking their lives and losing one
of the three dragons in order to Queen
Cersei that the army of the dead is real
a stupid and pointless smoothaise beside
losing one dragon Cersei will never help
her own enemies in the war no matter if
it's against night king this is
something since a knows because out of
all of them she's the one who spend the
most time in Cersei and she's the only
one who fully understands that Cersei
would never provide a living savage jobs
that she's likely to lose in a great war
and therefore weaken her position on the
Iron Throne as the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms sense of also warned Daenerys
that Cersei will likely take the
advantage of the war between the living
and dead which serves it confirmed
herself in the season 7 finale basically
while all of them are defending the
north one of the Seven Kingdoms Cersei
will achieve all other kingdoms that
were taken from her even though the
nurse in Tyrion will disagree with sense
as opinion Jaime will confirm these
statements once he reaches Winterfell
Daenerys and John are unaware of the
fact that a knight King and his army
have breached the wall and they're
marching south however it will be the
first thing they will learn upon
arriving at Winterfell as bran already
informed everyone since he himself or
his flock of Ravens witness the moment
when the night king destroyed a large
portion of the wall allowing his army to
march south shortly
Dejan engineers will organize an urgent
meeting with majority of the Northland
Lords at the Great Hall in order to
discuss their strategy and defenses one
of the most important events of the
season regarding the queen of dragons
will surely be her pregnancy and
eventual marriage with Jon Snow while
finding out the truth about Joshua
parentage is also important to highlight
as one of the season's biggest events
since John and Danny are headed to
Winterfell it's likely that bran and Sam
will reveal the truth about Joshua days
early on in the season
clearly this revelation of the nares
being John's aunt will come as a huge
shock to both of them and almost
certainly changed their relationship
there for many of you are probably
wondering why would they marry each
other upon finding out they are related
a few days ago I made the entire video
regarding this topic but if some of you
haven't seen Seattle I'm introduced with
the Targaryen wedding theory of mine in
a few sentences yes even though they
will at this point be aware of their
family ties John and Danny will marry in
the fifth episode of the final season
but no they will not marry out of love
nor because they want to seal their
alliance they will do it because of
their child John and Danny will not
continue their intimate relationship
after they found out the truth which
will by the way take place in the very
beginning of the final season but they
don't have to because the nurse already
got pregnant in the season 7 finale and
it might have been officially confirmed
a few days ago there's an inner ring in
which Game of Thrones showrunners David
and Dan are discussing the nurses
potential pregnancy with Kit Harington
an actor that portrays Jon Snow
it states the nurse says that she cannot
have children and you're like we'll see
about it unless one of the show runners
left regardless of the scenery of the
show's next big twist their child was
heavily foreshadowed throughout the
previous season multiple times that
Dana's pregnancy almost became a certain
thing the most prominent fan will
definitely be John statement on Danny's
believed that she cannot have children I
can't have children
my husband has it occurred to you she
might not have been a reliable source of
information
long story short even though both of
them without a doubt refuse to even
think about the marriage whether it's
political or out of love in the
beginning of the season upon learning
that their nephew and aunt they'll have
even stronger reason to do so later in
season and that reason is going to be
Denise's pregnancy John has been a
bastard son his entire life and he most
certainly will not allow his child to be
born out of wedlock and live a life he's
been living nor would the nearest one
that lie for her child
now let's see how Danny's role in Game
of Thrones might end the most
popular theory will definitely be Dennis
sacrifice and death in order to end the
long night both John and Danny are tied
to the other high prophecy which
includes a historic legend of a hero
sacrificing his love in order to save
the world from the long night
Monsanto Reddy told the nares that she
has a role to play in the prophecy as
does Jon Snow the nurse is rowland long
night in this theory would be her
eventual sacrifice and death it seems
that just like azor Ahai who had to joke
his sword into his wife's living heart
in order to create light bringer jana
have to do the same however while this
theory would most certainly match with
George RR Martin's announced bittersweet
ending I still believe in a theory of
mine that I introduced you with over a
year ago and is Daenerys becoming the
night's Queen before I introduced with
all the clothes that are supporting this
theory when we first will tell you a few
sentences about the night's Queen so you
could have an insight of what Danny
might become the night screen is an
unseen moment in Game of Thrones a
legendary figure known in Seven Kingdoms
and among the free folk according to
legend the Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch found in a haunted forest called
woman with bright blue eyes he took her
to the other side of the wall and
declared himself as the night's king
their love and reign lasted for 13 years
burp on the free folk rallied under the
banner of a king-beyond-the-wall in
march against the night's king seat
against the Nightfort resulted in the
night's king defeat vide eight of House
Stark now that you know a little bit
about the night's Queen let's start with
a theory in which the nurse'll become
the same Queen earlier in Game of
Thrones we've learned that the leader of
the White Walkers night King is able to
create other White Walkers
but it seems that he can only create one
if that human being is a pure-blooded
and says born as some kind of proof we
have a few scenes in which Craster had
been sacrificing as incest born babies
including a steam from the fourth season
in which Ross places Craster's final son
on a grounded haunted forest whereupon
White Walkers approached and took the
baby carried it towards the shattered
Mountain in the lands of always winter
once the white Walker approached an icy
altering by large icy spikes he plays
the baby upon the altar whereupon the
leader of the night King approached it
gently gathered the baby in his arms and
placed his index finger up on the baby's
cheek which caused the child's eye to
turn icy blue and its skin to grow pale
the same from the fourth episode of
season 4 in my opinion confirms my
statement that only says born pure
bloody human beings can become a white
Walker while every other human beings
can only become a white reanimated
corpse raised from the death by the
white walkers to act as their minions
all of this means that the night's king
could turn the nurse into one of them
since then is a pure blood
says born daughter of king Garrison
Queen rhaella Targaryen the only way for
the Lynx side to end the long night is
to either defeat them which would be
insanely hard evaded living sight is
definitely going to experience sort to
make a pact in my opinion the only way
the living side will had to end along
night after numerous battles and
enormous losses at that point will be a
pact an agreement with a leader of the
undead army and that same pact by
history would be a pact of Ice and Fire
an agreement that includes Daenerys I
was wondering why is the night king even
coming south why was he preparing the
armies same army with which he is
marching south at the moment of Dana's
arrival as I said in one of my first
videos I was wondering about that fact
since the sixth season ended and came to
a conclusion that Daenerys is arrival at
Westeros is the reason of the night
King's preparations the reason of his
march south and his the reason of every
single death that the Seven Kingdoms is
going to confront with this fury
midnight king is coming south for
tonight's Queen might have been hinted
earlier in Game of Thrones series I'm
talking about dense illusions that she
had in the house of the undying those
same illusions that might have a shared
of this theory in the series of
illusions of son Kairo visions that she
was created with the first term denier
centered after chasing the cry of her
dragons into the house of the undying
was a great whole of the red cape which
was covered by snow including the iron
throne whereupon she got so close to the
throne by decided to leave it untouched
I would say that this foreshadows that
Daenerys will answers his reign well she
loved India enthroned she will not be
able to sit on same since she'll have to
give up her life's waters including her
child could live those battles between
the link side and the White Walkers
accompanied with their white horde will
take a lot of casualties for both sides
but every casualty of the undead army
will be replaced with a casualty of the
linked side since all brave soldiers
that are going to sacrifice their life
on the battlefield in order to stop the
night King and his army will be raised
from death and will increase the numbers
of the undead army upon a huge amount of
casualties end up on realizing that
their chance to survive the long night
is small the linked side will decide to
stop fighting it will try to establish
peace will try to arrange a pact to the
leader of the white walkers now we're
coming to a pact that I mentioned
earlier in this video a pact between the
living side and the knight King an
agreement which Daenerys will accept and
the long night a pact in which she will
become the night's queen this is an
agreement virtual say Westeros sacrifice
which Daenerys as a true queen will
accept to save her people's lives
Daenerys the solutions are for sharing
that any will win the Iron Throne but
will realize that she will not be able
to sit on the same
she will have to give up on it since she
will give up her turn for the greater
good she looks at a pack that night King
in order to end the long night the nurse
will become a night's queen rep on the
night King and the night's queen will go
beyond wall and rule over it as a form
of peace agreement between the living
and the dead beside the nurses vision
says I've already said earlier in this
video
then his arrival at Westeros and the
night King's preparations and his march
to the south fits perfectly in timeline
and I don't think it's coincidence that
all those years the night King was
preparing an airing huge army with which
he started marching south at the same
time of Dana's arrival at Westeros not
only that history would be of the
greatest surprises that showrunners
could pull out but it would also fit
perfectly with the bittersweet ending
that george RR martin announced i cannot
tell this theory will surely come true
but in my opinion if the night King is
really marching south because of the
nearest nothing will be able to stop him
and his huge army nothing but an
agreement which then he would most
strongly accept in order to end the long
night and save Westeros from certain
death if you would like to know all
details about this tonight screen theory
of mine feel free to check out a video
by the name the night King is coming for
Daenerys there you have the guys Days
fate in vinyl season with two possible
endings Daenerys will either die in the
hands of the prince that was promised
Jon Snow will have to kill his wife in
order to create Lightbringer or will die
in the hands of the night king as the
nearest cent open her eyes as the Nights
Queen whatever the case the nurse will
have to sacrifice her life for the
greater good just as every true Queen
will do for the good of her people